foreign
oh
mangoes my bag of mangoes
I love mangoes too
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
be affected
don't want me to me
as highway robbery is what you doing
mangoes
[Music]
well welcome everybody we are standing
by for all sorts of extremely important
results most importantly maybe we are
moments away from Pennsylvania where we
will see does Trump's nomination still
have strength
and girth and power and all of these
different things in that Mehmet Oz will
win the Republican primary or will
Trump's nomination ultimately end up
flaccid and humiliating now what I don't
understand is where are my glitches
because anytime I mention Oz we've
endorsed JP right JD Mandel all right
let's listen folks here we go we'll see
how the Trump endorse Canada TV Doctor
Mehmet Oz fares against me very
competitive Challengers including the
late surgeon conservative Kathy Barnett
here's our evidence alert
it is too early to call Pennsylvania's
Republican Senate primary as of now the
very competitive three all right
extremely competitive now what's the
dream scenario tonight from the
standpoint of humiliation the dream is
that Mehmet loses and that Madison
cawthorne loses those are two
endorsements Trump waited until like
yesterday to do the the cothern
endorsement uh but it would be amazing
if Trump lost both and also Mehmet a
disgrace and cawthorne is a disgrace so
most importantly it would be a good
thing because of the element of politics
that are involved let's listen next
Pennsylvania Attorney General Josh
Shapiro okay will be the Democratic
nominee for Pennsylvania Governor
Shapiro Coast threw uncontested he will
face the winner of the Republican
gubernatorial Primary in the fall Dana
Bash Shapiro is uh counting on having
okay so let's get an update right now as
to where we are we have all of the
different results Happening Here uh
let's refresh and see where we stand as
of right now
um Pennsylvania gubernatorial primary we
are waiting
as just announced unopposed Josh Shapiro
one good thing imagine losing unopposed
that would be terrible
um we are waiting for our initial data
on the GOP Senate primary we are also
waiting for data over on the Democratic
side now incredibly you may or may not
know this John Federman had a stroke
over the weekend he literally
an hour and 22 minutes ago tweeted I
just got out of a procedure to implant a
pacemaker with the defibrillator in my
heart we got the all clear that it was
successful I'm on track for a full
recovery
um I believe that if this had happened
right before the General in November
this could have lost him the general
assuming he wins the primary of course
which I believe he will
um but fortunately he will most almost
certainly still win the Democratic
primary and we want him to be healthy
don't you want me to be healthy we want
him to be healthy uh whether it's from
eating fruit or whatever and
um
then then we will move on to the general
okay so we're keeping a very very close
eye on the circumstances there let me
close that out and then we will get back
over here
um other races right now
lieutenant governor in Pennsylvania okay
there's primaries there uh and then wait
a second why are we not
oh this is just oh I guess I need a tab
for each one okay so we'll go back here
North Carolina okay North Carolina Ted
Bud Richard Burr is retiring Richard
Burr is a republican he's retiring so
that will be an open seat an important
seat very important seat in the November
midterms we have the Senate Republican
primary where Ted Budd has already won
and then we have the Democratic primary
where Sherry Beasley just running away
with it absolutely running away with it
so we're watching that
now why isn't the cothorne thing oh wow
there's so many different pages the
North Carolina House primaries in the
which one are we interested in here
fourth what district is cawthorne
where on Earth is this
here it is North Carolina's 11th
District Madison cawthorne with 43
percent of the vote in is down 10.7 down
by 10.7 Pac-Man's a loser no no this
isn't about me
um it would be a massive
coup I mean it feels weird to use that
word now
it would be unbelievable to humiliate
Madison cawthorne and president Trump
after just one term
let's all pray I'm considering praying
that's how crazy this is for that to
happen now do we stop the count do we do
we continue the count do we count all
the ballots a second time I don't know
what we do right now but we hope and we
pray that that holds and let's see if we
got any additional data here uh oh oh my
with 1.3 percent of the vote Dave
McCormick has jumped out to an early
lead in Pennsylvania as some like to say
with quack Dr Mehmet Oz in second place
that's the Trump endorsed candidate and
absolute and complete lunatic dangerous
lunatic Kathy Barnett the boring guy
what was the boring's guy guy's name
mastos or something do you guys remember
what was that guy's name
he was the best candidate he seems to
have no votes
he's not even showing up here as having
any vote
um what was that guy's Bartos Bartos
he doesn't seem to be doing particularly
well right now okay so we're gonna watch
all of that very closely but what a
thrilling night it would be if uh we
were to see cawthorne and Oz go down and
as you all know I don't even know how
many votes we need at this point I need
11 thousand votes give me a break right
we're going to be watching all of that
very closely welcome everybody it's so
great to have you here it is an election
night and we are starting to get numbers
let's look at some early Su these are
early super chats we don't want to make
any final calls because these are just
early
Jesse says thanks for doing this David
very interested in the cawthorne race by
the way was it you that introduced Joe
Joe Walsh to mangas oh you guys have to
see this
this this is this is a major coup for
fruit okay yesterday actually wait a
second no there's an easier way to do
this
yesterday Joe Walsh tweeted
where was this
Joe Walsh tweeted yesterday I just ate a
mango for the first time in my life and
I effing loved it and as you can see I'm
right there in the replies I said
basically the top fruit out there I
recently did interview Joe Walsh I
cannot I would be lying if I said that
the topic of mangoes came up during the
interview that would be a lie I would
love to tell you that I illuminated Joe
Walsh into the area of mangoes I really
can't take credit for that but a lot of
people noticing that and feeling really
strongly about it
Bay photo oh hold on key race alert here
thinking uh let's go to the Republican
Senate primary right now uh CNN with one
percent of the vote in has Dave
McCormick in the lead position 42.6
percent of the vote he is 2 418 votes
ahead of Mehmet Oz the Trump endorsed
candidate the TV Doctor Who has 22.7
people died and Firebrand Kathy Barnett
has 15.6 of the vote that is only with
one percent of the vote in uh but right
now at this hour Dave McCormick has the
lead on the Democratic side uh John
fetterman the lieutenant governor has a
whopping 57.4 percent of the vote
against 13
604 votes ahead of Congressman Connor
lamb who has 39.7 percent of the vote
and state representative Malcolm
Kenyatta from the Philadelphia area who
has 2.1 percent of the vote that is with
a minority this is all pretty exciting
I can barely contain myself I know bay
photo with the Super Chat the GOP drip
campaign just might work I'll be damned
John says just voted in my local school
board election the CRT and grooming
stuff is working yeah that is that is
scary stuff uh all right let's continue
welcoming people in because it is a very
special evening I actually may do a
twitch ban unban requests I've actually
accumulated 14 of them I'm considering
doing that today I want to say major
thank yous to Charles Weiland junk Saint
and JP de Beast for the twitch Prime
subscriptions we are also seeing seeing
memberships dump in on the website I
want to say thanks to Catherine Spencer
whose new member number four today and
Kevin gouldi gifting another membership
that's number five and I'm glad to give
that membership away to Kiana Avalon
Kiana Avalon if you want a free
membership
go to davidpackman.com free membership
and of course you can gift memberships
at joinpakman.com uh Madison cawthorne
is still down let's look that at the
geographic breakdown of the early vote
in Pennsylvania you you can stick in
Pennsylvania and uh Dave McCormick doing
well it's early one percent in but Dave
McCormick uh doing well right now it is
early Jake and that's the key Point
again 67 counties in the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania Allegheny county is the
only one reporting votes so far perhaps
that will change it up and does right as
we start to count them this is the
second largest county in the state just
shy of 10 of the population so it
matters it's a big population Center but
we have seen in the Ohio Senate race and
the Nebraska's governor's race a more
moderate these are all conservatives
running but you would say Dave McCormick
is the most moderate or the least
conservative of the leading Senate
candidates here maybe Dr Oz would
disagree with that but he pull out in
the early vote you've seen this repeat
Time After Time After Time right so
needless to say we don't really know
anything yet it's very early there's
basically some results from Pittsburgh
and Pittsburgh doesn't seem to like
Mehmet so we we can't we can't glean too
much from that quite yet Adam Gingrich
says via Super Chat let's take back the
word Patriot for equality and justice
Warriors well said
Mark says David will you speak in
tongues if Madison cawthorne loses
please strike and strike and
actually sir if Madison cawthorne loses
will he call for a class action lawsuit
against all machines we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines RJ
says bobert has some good Democrat
running for her District but it's gone
red for a very long time also a moderate
Republican that came out of retirement
to run I have to I haven't looked into
that one super strongly yet
is it good if mainstream Republicans win
today even if they beat Democrats in
general elections so we get the nut jobs
out of the running this is a very
important thing okay so let's just speak
honestly for a moment if I can
um the truth is that this is just my
feeling I this could be completely wrong
things could change between now and
November okay assuming fetterman wins
the Democratic primary which I I believe
he will in in Pennsylvania
my instinct is that the lunatic cat oh
look Bartos got some votes that's good
my instinct is that the lunatic Kathy
Barnett is the one that would be most
likely to lose to fetterman
at the same time
we don't want someone so crazy to be the
nominee and we want Trump not to get his
Mehmet Oz Victory so that basically from
who's in in it right now leaves Dave
McCormick however it's probably true
that Dave McCormick is more likely to
defeat fetterman I think McCormick will
do better against fetterman
I don't know about again versus Oz but
certainly compared to Kathy Barnett so
that's a real question the good thing is
I have no control over it and so all we
can do is wait for the results and as
the results continue to come in in North
Carolina Madison cawthorne is not doing
great at this point in time and you love
to see that David I know you have a few
Canadian fans can you ask them to
recommend Canadian political YouTubers
sure people in the chat if you're from
Canada and you'd like to recommend some
political YouTubers in Canada by all
means
Ben says let's pretend Pac-Man is
elected POTUS in 24 with the majority
blue Congress What policies with POTUS
Pacman Administration like to see
implemented oh I've answered this so
many times I don't even want you I can't
even legally be president
so let's let's not let's not do that
right now
Bay photo says with the way things are
going or Trump is candidates going to
declare in-party voter fraud it would be
fascinating if tomorrow after the
primary
one of these candidates claims voter
fraud listen how what would they say I
can tell you exactly what they would say
they would say
The Establishment wants a weaker
Republican so they helped my opponent
that's what they say that's what they
will say
uh no question about it Dave Wasserman
called it for fetterman on Twitter yeah
not surprising fetterman was was looking
very very good from early on
so no surprise there and with two
percent reporting Now Dave Dave
McCormick still in the lead which is a
great thing uh but
anyone but Oz I just want to see Trump
lose I'm not saying I prefer McCormick
to Barnett Barnett is the wackiest for
sure arguably the most dangerous thanks
to Jen here for the gifted twitch sub
your number six today I really
appreciate your support also want to say
thank you to coupon code isn't working
someone named coupon code isn't working
just gifted a subscription and that
subscription goes to Mark bussin Mark
bussin gets that free membership okay
let's uh where do we want to go next I
have a few things to look at here
uh so we did fetterman had a stroke very
sad news
um I don't know that we want to spend a
ton of time on this but Jimmy Dore is
now straight up saying you gotta vote
Trump
um he's gone full Maga
so what were they really afraid of with
Trump they were afraid he wouldn't do
this
that's what they are afraid of they were
afraid he wouldn't go along with them
because he didn't come up in the
Republican farm team he didn't come up
in the organization he didn't have
groomers Trump trump didn't have donors
it what's the is that just the word of
the day now everybody's using the term
groomers is that that seems to be what's
going on
for his whole life like everybody else
he was a donor
so he didn't owe favors like everybody
else they couldn't control him like they
could control everybody so what they did
was they concocted Russia gate red
baited him for four straight years and
impeached him twice
because he didn't have his mind right
so if you were the anti-war person you
should have voted for Trump and the
Republicans right that's what this means
if you're pro-war you vote for Joe Biden
and the Democrats the last true liberal
the only remaining actual Progressive
if you're on the left
there is only one path forward at this
point in time
and that is Jimmy Dore
that is Jimmy Dore he's the only true
liberal left
um Lauren bobert had a glitch she
couldn't remember that George Orwell
wrote 1984. you guys are I mean you guys
are familiar with glitches right I mean
you know truth essential DHS
is a militarized form uh arm of the
government they have means to enforce uh
this disinformation governance board or
if anyone has read the 1984 book by uh
uh the the and heard about the organs
yes
um you know okay all right that's pretty
good cephahide
so that was that
um continuing but it's early we're also
keeping a close eye on a GOP House
Primary in North Carolina where Scandal
plagued incumbent Congressman Madison
cawthorne is trailing as of right now
we'll be right back after this quick
break
so very very important stuff happening
there ladies and gentlemen uh thank you
to Roan Ron is twitching for the twitch
Prime subscription You're Number Eight
today also want to say thank you to Paul
Crawford Paul just did a beautiful thing
and has gifted a membership on my
website I'm glad to give that membership
to Levi Farr or Levy Farr
um you'll get an email in the next few
days John Simon via Super Chat says
rational National is a Great Canadian
YouTuber that's a good recommendation
Joe Rader says what's everyone's food
for the stream the Raider house is
enjoying homemade palak paneer on
jasmine rice which one is palak paneer I
mean paneer is the you know the cheese
palak paneer oh it's the spinach with
paneer that's that's not a bad dish
uh I am partial to tandoori chicken
uh I like a chicken aubergine aubergine
some people know it as eggplant I know
it is aubergine like that
chana masala is a beautiful dish a lot
of great dishes out there really really
a lot of great dishes hard to beat
um okay let's un let's look at unbanning
a few people from twitch as we wait for
additional results remember if you get
banned from twitch there is a sort of a
democratic process we call it due
process where you can ask to be unbanned
14 people have done that oh and thanks
to gendrick sorry for gifting five
subscriptions on Twitch uh I would I
used to have a gavel when I would say
banned or unbanned my gobble is broken
it's just it's horrible what's going on
so let's just go through some of these
okay we'll start with the oldest ones
and we'll see if we need to uh
uh let's see if we unban these people
user salad snack was banned like months
ago for saying Pac-Man you are literally
[ __ ] you have AIDS of the brain
they were banned they asked to be
unbanned with the message I would like
to tell your chat what pieces of s you
and they are once again so that's a
perma-ban uh just that's easy you're
gone
um let's see Trump will win 24 Biden and
the Democrats are a disaster uh
attacking others is delusional telling
people to go f themselves
saying uh
Bernie has a cult
telling other people to go f themselves
they were banned they said I'm sorry for
my actions I got triggered and let my
emotions get the best of me won't happen
again I'm fine to unban with that the
original infraction wasn't that bad and
they've apologized so they're unbanned
user me me me
said lib Cox can't stand a strong white
woman who knows she's right Marjorie is
winning bigly
they came back and said lib Cox can't
stand a strong white woman who's right
they came back and said Marjorie Taylor
green for president they were banned and
then this user said I was memeing why
the ban am I not allowed to stir up chat
Obama okay so that's deliberate trolling
that's a perma-ban you're gone
user crash burn
said Biden is a much better speaker like
when Biden [ __ ] himself on television
Biden legit fell downstairs and [ __ ] his
pants on live TV they were banned and
then he said why was I banned I thought
differing opinions were tolerated yeah
uh [ __ ] his pants on live TV twice we're
not going to do that so that's a
permaban I'm having no trouble
uh adjudicating these These are easy
user button clicker said your Discord
moderators are out of control make your
own site instead of being a leech on
YouTube Facebook and twitch
why are you on Twitch they were banned
he then came back and said every single
Republican is an effing scumbag F all of
them even the voters
uh
it's a little too unhinged so I think
it's just going to be a perma-band I'm
not liking the vibe let's get an update
here people played Madison call Thorne
right now behind with
27.6 as the votes continue to come in
and be counted we should point out that
the senator Tom Tillis endorsed uh state
Senator Chuck Edwards instead of Madison
Hawthorne in this race let's go to Diane
Gallagher at the cawthorne headquarters
Diane it would be so amazing If
cawthorne lost it would just be the best
in for two years humiliates himself
loses I would love it I would absolutely
love it
um okay I want to say thank you to
brancel Branded b as well as your
billion for the twitch Prime
subscriptions also a twitch viewer con
queso that means with cheese in my
native Spanish has uh re-upped the
twitch Prime subscription also big big
thank you to Kevin Alves who has gifted
a subscription Kevin is new member
number 18 today and that subscription
goes to
Augustine CL very very much appreciate
that super chat's continuing to come in
Sir with peace and love you love you
said Twitter should not permaban users
but you are permabanning people please
explain that's exactly right the people
that I am permabanning
were not by default permaband it was a
provisional ban I then examined the ban
and then adjudicate the permaband it
should not be a default permaband and
that is exactly what I advocated for and
it's exactly what I'm doing so really
appreciate that let's do a couple others
um
let's see here Reggie renji rimmins
showed up and said
does this Pac-Man guy ever add anything
useful
guys it's well known the FBI did all the
bad stuff the trumpists were just
sitting in chairs
um
I'll subscribe if you add anything funny
they were banned their unbanned request
was just an emoji that's a perma-band we
don't need you here
so you're gone
all right we'll go back to this I think
I'm all set with with unbanned requests
for the time being let's look at a
couple of other things that I had ready
for you here uh this is these are our
friends over at the good liars they were
talking to a trumpist about the meaning
of let's go Brandon this is the new hot
phrase among some on the right to people
that don't know what does let's go
Brandon mean what does everybody want to
do here [ __ ] Joe Budden and if you had
the opportunity would you [ __ ] Joe Biden
not literally okay but you figuratively
figuratively yeah figuratively you would
have sex with Joe Biden no
literally
you'd [ __ ] Joe bye no
figuratively you wouldn't have sex with
Joe Biden correct I would never have sex
with Joe Biden but you [ __ ] Brandon
that's pretty good uh I like that one I
mean it's very silly but I actually kind
of like it that's pretty good
um here's Steve Bannon predicting that
everybody running Twitter is going to
end up in jail that seems extremely
unlikely to me three November think of
every important topic of our time that
this nation would not beware it is today
but those punks out there they're all
going to go to prison because they've
lied and lied and lied and lied also
looking extremely red and sweaty and it
was Elon Musk in his deal that brought
up like we said
I told him to pull it and play Smash
Mouth well now he is all of them should
go to prison
these cocky smug arrogant
they know better than you they're going
to suppress you they're going to shut
your voice down they're not going to
talk about the laptop from hell and
allow Biden to go in there then is he
saying that Twitter employees or Twitter
users should go to jail now I actually
can't tell patient is where it is
because of them they took Donald Trump
the commander-in-chief off the platform
and they suppressed all the information
about Biden then they suppressed all the
information about the three November
steel then they suppressed all the
information about the Wuhan lab in fauci
then they suppressed on and on and on
and on any topic and do they want to do
they care about due process with are
they saying jail these people after
finding them guilty of a crime or do
they just want them jailed topic of
urgency to the American people there's
smugness in there well we don't know
you're going to prison because you have
lied that stock is going to go to zero
because nobody can trust you you're
nothing but a pack of liars man really
orange Steve Bannon huh take a look at
the oranges of the investigation yeah
I'll say very very strange stuff okay so
there's that
um
okay so we dealt with that just so much
to keep up on and so many different
races in four minutes at the bottom of
the hour we will do another tour through
all of the results but there are many
many results coming in if you're just
joining us guys we have two bits two
pieces of good news potentially good
news one Madison cawthorne's down by
eight
now he was down by 11 so the lead is
shrinking but Madison cawthorne is down
by eight you love to see it also Mehmet
Oz is losing by 13. that's however with
only two percent reporting Pennsylvania
you may recall not exactly fast at
counting ballots and I don't know if
they are doing ballot harvesting I don't
know if they're curing ballots or
trafficking them it's not clear if they
have cold or hot smoked any ballots or
if any ballots have been found to be
covered in barbecue sauce grain or spicy
or even Dijon mustard we don't know the
status of a lot of these Pennsylvania
ballots but they're going to be looking
very closely as to whether they've been
marinated
any of these things these are fishy
things that could attract attention
in some kind of disagreement in the
future
uh in some they found a very particular
type of rice only native to a did not
the U.S and they want to know how did
that type of rice get on the ballot they
don't know
they don't know thanks to any 43 and
Alton's gaming for the twitch Prime
subscriptions numbers 19 and 20. a Super
Chat says Derek Marshall for California
house d23 by Jay obernelt I don't know
about that one young Festa but we're
gonna try to find out about all of these
okay we're looking at all of these okay
bottom of the hour roughly let's take a
look at all of the results that we have
so far or at least some of them in
Pennsylvania
in the Republican primary for governor
Bill McSwain has jumped out to a lead
and Josh Shapiro one ran unopposed very
important race maybe one of the most
important because Pennsylvania could
determine whether Democrats or
Republicans ultimately control the
Senate
on the Republican side
Mehmet Oz is the television doctor
endorsed by President Trump right now
he's down by 13. it is only about three
and a half percent of the vote that is
in over on the Democratic side John
fetterman is leading and Dave Wasserman
has already called it for John fetterman
um I uh uh
I I mean endorsed I don't really endorse
but I like John fetterman if I voted in
Pennsylvania I would have voted for
fetterman and that's a really great
thing it is over there according to Dave
Wasserman in North Carolina Ted Budd has
already won the Senate Republican
primary Richard Burrs a Republican
senator who's retiring would be a
beautiful seat for Democrats to steal
and remember by steal I mean
democratically win you know you know
what I'm talking about and then
um on the Senate uh Democratic side
Sherry Beasley won so uh no no real
groundbreaking news there but we are
looking at this race right here
with Now 50 of the vote in Madison
cawthorne the incumbent Trump endorsed
member of Congress who has recently been
cited multiple times for trying to bring
a gun through airport security uh
reckless driving speeding all these
different things he is now losing by 8.1
and I would really like to see him lose
now I don't know anything about Chuck
Edwards in theory it's possible Chuck
Edwards is even crazier I just doubt it
it's just hard to believe BR says
Pac-Man's on fire tonight sir hold on
where's my sir
oh no where is this thing
uh I had this sir compilation and I
can't even find it now
that's too bad
no I'm gonna have to get that on my uh I
have the file
I just don't know where it is
okay
so needless to say we're watching many
many many of these races and expecting
an update momentarily which I mean I the
pencil I don't want to get people's uh
expectations up necessarily
I don't know whether we will necessarily
have the Republican numbers tonight from
Pennsylvania but if it stays with this
level of margin we will in like probably
an hour
so that'll be very interesting sir is
the Republican Party tanking Hawthorne
on purpose because of the Coke and orgy
comments he made it does seem that way
yeah
it does seem that well people are asking
whether I'll be covering the results on
May 24th I think May 24th there's
actually a bunch of Elections let me
take a look here election calendar
this is a good page that I use
so on the 24th we've got Alabama oh wow
the 24th is stacked Alabama Arkansas
oh I don't want this how can I close
that Alabama Arkansas Georgia Minnesota
New York South Carolina and Texas oh
yeah uh barring unforeseen circumstances
I will be streaming on the 24th probably
won't stream on the 21st
that's what's Saturday yeah I don't
think I'll be streaming on the 21st but
next Tuesday you you better believe it
that's a that's a major major number of
major races on that day super jets keep
coming in 121 says thanks for what you
do David thank you for the support
grundle Grump says I like fetterman but
him and his girlfriend look like Uncle
Fester and Morticia Adams ran away
together I don't disagree with that and
I have a key race alert for you right
now for the Pennsylvania Senate race on
the Republican side hedge fund CEO Dave
McCormick wow remains in first place
with 36.2 percent of the vote about 4
500 votes ahead of mehmed Oz the TV
Doctor Who has 23.1 percent of the vote
and in third place as of right now A
Kathy Barnett the radio Firebrand who
has 17.2 percent of the vote that's with
only two percent of the estimated vote
in still a lot of votes to count now
let's go to the Democratic side where
Lieutenant Governor John Federman
remains in the lead
0.8 percent of the vote almost 35
000 votes ahead of Congressman Connor
lamb who has 33.3 percent of the vote
and state legislator Malcolm Kenyatta
who is at 12.1 percent of the vote
that's with a little bit more uh of the
vote in about 16 there Kristen Holmes is
at McCormick headquarters in Pittsburgh
uh Kristen what is the McCormick Camp
saying about this early lead
well look advisors here are still saying
it's anyone's game but they do see a
passive victory for the former hedge
fund CEO they were unnerved last week
when they saw this late Surge from Kathy
Barnett believing it came for months of
mudslinging between Oz and McCormick
really opening up a lane poor Barnett to
succeed they decided to replicate this
strategy allow Oz and Barnett to tear
each other apart and take this home out
of it hoping that he would have his own
link essentially what they did was they
hold most of his negative ads replace
them with ads about Hope and optimism
for the country yeah the background
noise is pretty unbearable there
um so we're it's still early they're
absolutely right it is funny to hear
it's TV Doctor Mehmet Oz radio Firebrand
Kathy Barnett
and then millionaire hedge fund guy uh
Dave McCormick which is interesting oh I
do want to hear from the fetterman camp
though Federman he's in the hospital
right now after getting a pacemaker
implanted today uh what's he doing as
the results come in
well we know I was just talking with
person and he told
things come in along with his dad his
brother his campaign manager so they're
about four hours away from us we're
currently in Pittsburgh we are expecting
to hear from his wife Giselle and their
children they are here but again the
lieutenant governor not the night he
thought he would be having in terms of
where he thought he would be and how he
would be taking all of this in he is in
that hospital room recovering from
having the pacemaker put in earlier
today uh they say that it went very well
that he is expected to make a full
recovery this is after he suffered a
stroke on Friday Jake that took him off
the trail for the last five days those
key last days on the trail but the
campaign says they feel very good about
where they stand United as they watch
these returns come in all right Jessica
Dean thanks so much we'll have more
results from the great Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania after this quick break stay
with us all right so the news for
fetterman good health news after a scare
and good at uh electoral news as well so
far fetterman I believe is 52. let me
see double check his age he is indeed 52
years old that's right born in 1969. uh
yeah thanks to Friend Of Monsters And
Titan Mars productions for the twitch
Prime subscriptions numbers 21 and 22.
Jeff and Boston asks when will the mules
arrive in Asheville to bring ballots
with votes for Edwards let me ask you
it's a good joke Jeff in all seriousness
my feeling is I've talked about the
Dinesh D'Souza
film 2 000 mules enough it's basically
um Geo mobile phone geolocation data of
limited accuracy used to extrapolate
that people were doing massive dumps of
trafficked ballots all over various
States it's it's complete nonsense but
but I got a really good email from one
of our viewers named
uh
uh actually I don't know that they
didn't sign the email which kind of goes
through Point by point the film
debunking each element of it would that
be a worthwhile segment to do I don't
know
I don't know it's kind of like it's so
stupid that I don't want to give it too
much more attention but at the same time
maybe it's worth doing just to have a
segment like that on the record I don't
know oh people are saying yeah
okay well I'll look at it I'll look at
doing that
thanks to Blueberry babe and true dark
Mason for the twitch Prime subscriptions
numbers 23 and 24. I did have a couple
of other things I wanted to look at with
you guys this is really funny
um I can't stand Dan Crenshaw Dan
Crenshaw is this member of Congress
Republican who says wacky things about
socialism which we've debunked Etc don't
care about uh defending his political
views but he's a veteran who lost an eye
while serving as a veteran he wears an
eye patch in 2018 Tucker Carlson
criticized Pete Davidson
for making fun of the eye patch and then
last night Tucker Carlson made fun of
the eye patch check this out this is
wild Texas Congressional candidate Dan
Crenshaw lost an eye to an IED in
Afghanistan on Saturday actor Pete
Davidson mocked him as one of the quote
really gross people running for office
this year he said added I'm sorry I know
he lost his eye in war or whatever
yeah so that's their position and
they're not hiding it anymore useful for
you to know the more I okay so wow
Tucker pissed off that they're being
demeaning towards veterans think about
it it takes a lot of gall for eye patch
McCain to attack moms you're worried
about baby formula as quote pro-russia I
mean that's eye patch McCain wait a
second guys Tucker did the thing that he
said is bad
when other people do it oh oh another oh
okay when other people do it I forgot
about that
so there's Tucker with brilliant
insights I don't even I'm gonna do this
on the show tomorrow
this is wild this gentleman goes by the
name I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly hotep Jesus am I saying that
right is that the correct pronunciation
I
can't think of any other way it would be
pronounced
a rhino named Mitt Romney yeah all right
that's hotep Jesus hotep Jesus was on
with Joe Rogan
in this two and a half minute clip
they promulgate fake news after spending
a bunch of the episode
criticizing fake news
and then they seem almost upset that the
news is fake just let me let allow this
to develop okay you know I want to find
out what this is but I read something
briefly and I didn't get into the
article but they were saying that they
were trying to pass a bill that would
outlaw you growing your own food in
Australia oh my God that that's crazy
they they want people to starve in
Australia oh my god did you read that no
it was a part of Australia I think it
was New South Wales someone's trying to
pass a law that won't allow you to grow
your own food and they were saying well
you could grow your own food and what
else the diseases from your food it
infects the population kills us all we
can have that they pulled that that car
I want to know what what their
justification was but I'm pretty sure it
had to do with like agricultural
contamination or you know like I mean
that sounds terrible Justified if you're
a real piece of [ __ ] you could say well
you know most pandemics have come from
agriculture my animal agriculture we can
have unchecked pig ownership that's not
fair we can UV grown vegetables what
have your vegetables ever got in them
and diseases
[ __ ] creeps man these [ __ ] creeps
they these crazy people trying to stop
people from growing food add a good grip
on people during the pandemic they're
locked their way down Australia and then
you know what just stick with stuff
these [ __ ] when we're on their
own food because that's how you [ __ ]
smoke out an anti-vaxxer make you can't
even grow their go to the grocery store
anymore and you can't grow your food no
dependent take that shot [ __ ] do you
find anything you are now dependent upon
this thing
so now they're not finding Jamie's not
finding the article
so now it starts to get a little
complicated asses bill I mean I know
what to look for I'm just it's not
nothing's coming up uh the closest thing
I could find was something like this I
don't that's not your food no it's
nothing it's not New Zealand it's in uh
it's in Australia I know but this is
close New Zealand is like right around
the corner could have right um there's
got it's got to be a real thing it seems
too good to not be it's it's obviously
um I typed in uh Outlaw growing food in
Australia and nothing not a single thing
comes up
hold on except for that which was a
false thing
growing your own food they want they
want us completely dependent
yeah they want us completely dependent
based on the story they can't find oh
wait a second either oh damn it
cannot be fake
it might be fake yeah but even if it's
fake right like the fake is usually the
warning
oh
that's too good even even if it's fake
they're probably thinking about that
they're probably going to do it anyway
it says hotep Jesus uh even if it's fake
it's the oh that is just brilliant uh
okay so anyway that was on the um that
was on The Joe Rogan program
uh for people wondering about that and a
complete fake story just absolutely fake
um it's fake but it must probably be
true shmoab says there's elements of
runoffs in North Carolina you must get
30 percent to avoid one for cawthorne oh
that's important okay wait who needs to
get 30 the winner needs to get at least
thirty percent is that what you're
saying
I'm actually not familiar with the rule
in North Carolina and a 50 Super Chat
from Vijay alluru I really appreciate
that and appreciate everybody who's here
today we will be streaming uh next
Tuesday we've got all the results coming
we're going to be streaming the January
6th committee hearings which are going
to be explosive starting on June 9th
we're streaming all of it we're
streaming all of it guys this is county
by county by the way just for everybody
to know they're looking county by county
right now uh on on the screen
okay let's uh let's look at a couple of
other things here if we can
um
oh you've got by the way speaking of two
thousand mules listen to this voicemail
that just came in
ah Dave
it's Michael John Brian
I just wanted to know your thoughts on
how the demographics use 2 000 mules to
steal the election okay I think this is
a this is a parody this has got to be a
parody
a sought a documentary it's good lots of
proof everything can come crumbling down
you're going to report on that sauce boy
King
anyways
let's go Brandon is I actually
we have a circumstance
in the United States
where I can't tell whether that's real
or a joke
if the country were more sane we could
all say
obviously that's fake obviously that's a
joke nobody like that would be real
but this is the United States of America
in 2022 and I can't tell you whether
that's real or fake it it may be real
it may be real and people in the chat
seem to think that it's real
would you ever go back on Rogan or is
the bridge burned I would go back
anytime if I was invited I don't know
that he will ever have me back but I
would go back on Rogan anytime
let's hear some more Trump
mispronouncing names I actually do I
have the
oh hold on a second
I don't think I've gotta fix what's
going on here I had Trump mispronouncing
Indian names oh here it is hold on check
this out Swami Vive come on right
[Music]
there it is yeah there's Trump
mispronouncing Indian uh Indian names
um
we also have Trump mispronouncing his
own name which is weird anyway
and mispronouncing Barack Obama's name
[Music]
um people asking did I see that Jordan
Peterson left Twitter yeah so tomorrow I
am going to do a segment on the podcast
in the last 24 hours Jordan Peterson
flipped out on me on Twitter
minutes after flipping out on me he
called some woman on the cover of Sports
Illustrated ugly
and then announced that he's told his
staff to change his password not to give
it back to him and that he's leaving
Twitter that's those are the last 24
hours from Jordan Peterson bizarre
bizarre
Haley from Georgia says 11
780 mules exactly right
David sir wanted to let you know DAV
Rams from the good Liars full name is
DAV Ram stiefler that's his name oh okay
DAV Ram stiefler is that is that German
is that Hebrew I don't I've never I'm
not familiar with that name davram
Stifler Stifler
it fascinating name anybody know the
oranges of that
man I don't I don't that's that's a good
that's a very interesting name anyway we
love the guys over at the good liars
they do great stuff what's your view on
runoffs do they make sense should the
winner in the primary take it regardless
of percentage no I I do think that in
general
runoffs aren't illogical because if you
have a race with a hundred candidates
and the person who got the most vote got
1.2 percent and everybody else got .9 or
whatever it's weird to make that person
the winner so I do think that in general
I'm okay with a runoff
but I think the thresholds need to be
properly set I think that's that's where
I would uh where I would leave it if
you're just joining us we have some very
very exciting news first and foremost
Madison cawthorne for now is losing his
primary although he is now pulled much
closer he is only 5.7 percentage points
with 60 of the vote in
uh behind first place we would love love
love to see Madison cawthorne lose and
then meanwhile Mehmet Oz with seven
percent of the votin
is down by what is that 9.5
and I would love to see Mehmet lose
conceivably Donald Trump could get two
losses tonight
which would just be great
it would be great the maggoteers will
flow tonight says Jordan Mills how long
before they say the elections were
stolen tonight yeah like I said earlier
it I would not put it past some
Republicans or Trump to say
it was rigged tonight
establishment rhinos
rigged it so that the magats would lose
I I think it's completely plausible that
they would say that tonight who what who
obviously they would say that
um so we're going to be here to to
figure out whether that indeed is going
to be the case all right everybody okay
let me um let me mention
we have
dozens of streams planned we will
continue sending correspondence to Trump
rallies and other events and we will
continue the podcast all the way up
through and Beyond the midterms my only
request to you it's a very small favor I
need 11
right no no no no no no no no no it's a
completely legal favor
I would love for you to get a membership
on my website we we actually we do
depend on the support of our audience so
like we have a team we have staff I try
to be a good boss and provide vacation
health care all these different things
um and everybody works really hard a lot
of the days are really long and I would
love for you to support the work we're
doing you can do that on my website
joinpakman.com it only takes a second
you can use the coupon code Obama if you
want Obama to save like 70 or something
like that and you know how they say on
airplanes
if the oxygen masks come down put your
mask on first and then help others
around you
first get yourself a membership
if you have one then you can also gift
them using this box this is a gift
there are currently
485 people waiting
praying for a free membership I I I'm
not exaggerating I have 485 requests for
free memberships uh and we will fulfill
them as they come in okay so that's my
request to you we really do depend on
that you know we've seen twitch cut us
off we've seen YouTube cut us off we've
seen Facebook cut us off everybody's cut
us off at some point okay and so uh it's
sort of like Insurance oh wow someone's
pledging 485 memberships
key Pusher I pledge 480 key Pusher if
you're serious
please get in touch that would be a bit
we I will take 485 memberships sure
sure wow
that's incredible
that would be wild
it's an Amber Heard joke
oh the pleasuring oh I'm so stupid yeah
Hey listen by the way this whole thing
does any does anybody really believe
Amber Heard thinks pledging and donating
are the same things
I just fell for it I'm such an idiot I I
forgot about it I'm so sucked into these
results that I forgot about it
I've dealt with situations where people
will write to me
in fact if I went into my email and I
searched for pledge
I will find probably a dozen or so
people who have contacted me saying I
want to make a pledge and then we never
get the money and it reminds me of the
Seinfeld episode where Jerry makes a car
reservation and he's told by the car
rental agency we have the reservation we
don't have the car
and of course Jerry explains anybody can
just take reservations you've got to
hold it and have a car right well
otherwise what what does it even mean to
have a reservation similarly
I've received a number of pledges and we
didn't get the money
okay also yes she said it's like when
you buy a house it's like Amber do you
understand that when you get a mortgage
at the time that you take possession of
the house the seller has gotten all the
money it's just that you now owe the
bank I mean it was it was
wild why it was a
I hate to say it
it was a kafka-esque moment I know that
there are people who don't like that
term
but it was a kafka-esque moment for sure
um but anyway yeah no I I get the joke
good someone pledged 485 memberships
doesn't seem like uh doesn't seem like
we're going to be getting them
um okay other super chats here Tina
matching
vijay's 50 Super Chat
with no message just a 50 Super Chat
appreciate that very much
David what happened to the briefly
mentioned sharts coming to YouTube so
the YouTube shorts which is known
colloquially as YouTube sharts they are
in full swing we are we are doing them
we are doing them it's all it's all
happening all right let's give away some
memberships guys I want to say thank you
to Kevin gouldy hold on people are
dumping in memberships Zachary Egan
I can barely keep up with this Adam
Gingrich has gifted another one
Zach Heintz that's four gifted
memberships putting us at 28 those go to
a nearby
Marshall Bell
Kenneth Hughes
and Ron MKZ
Ron apparently a fan of the vehicle the
Lincoln MKZ very much appreciate that
also thanks to Chuck Conklin who just
got himself a membership and is number
29 will I open the phones if we get to a
hundred sure
why not why not I will do it
uh Colin sends a super chat for 6.66
Viper Says do you think Bloomberg will
get back into politics why or why not
why is he been silent no I don't think
he will Michael Bloomberg is now 80
years old I think he's good I think
correct me if I'm wrong guys but I
believe uh
I think Bloomberg is done with politics
maybe maybe funding right but I don't
think he's going to run for anything
thank you to any and zero cool for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
31. uh we are continuing to watch really
the most important races tonight our two
races in which Donald Trump has a horse
uh in the race those are Pennsylvania
Republican where he endorsed Mehmet Oz
and right now Mehmet Oz is not winning
and in North Carolina where he endorsed
Madison cawthorne and right now Madison
cawthorne is not winning
I'm delighted to see both of those
things and I believe that in five
minutes at the top of the hour we're
going to get some additional very very
important results I want to say thank
you to May Rican for gifting 10
subscriptions on Twitch and also
creative pixie for signing up via twitch
Prime over on the website Joseph
Flanagan has just signed up and so has
Della de la Garza new members 43 and 44.
will you be covering the California
primary on June 7th especially Los
Angeles mayoral yes I plan to
that is enough if it's a Tuesday and
there's elections my plan is to stream
unless for whatever reason you know
something happens
uh but that is absolutely the plan we're
going to do all of it
we're going to do all of it
okay I want to say thanks to Stanley
minarich Stanley just gifted a
subscription that's number 45 I'm glad
to give that one away
to Eric Walker Eric Gets a membership
also thanks to Peter Hudson whoa
a lot of people named Peter Peter toker
toker's tokerick Peter tokerick
um Elliott Cooper has just signed up
and Joel pitra all new members putting
us at 49
. hey you know what just for number 50
number 50 gets a free item from my
online store could be a mug could be a
hat t-shirt whatever you want next
person to sign up on my website number
50 gets a free item the fact Republicans
are sickened by the other side the same
way we are is maddening how can people
allow themselves to be so fully deluded
and exploited that's a question for the
ages
that's uh that's a question for the ages
I've got a couple other things oh we did
the mango stuff already we don't have
that
um oh yeah there was a Walter Masterson
thing let me see if I can find it
alter Masterson Twitter
he did a couple other videos
um
oh here it is yeah check this out he's
been doing some really great stuff and
Walter went to a Clarence Thomas's house
this is pretty interesting check out
what happened
with crossing rivers uh Church of we
came out here just to do like little
silent prayers they were like a place
that we can put up that's not going to
be in anyone's way
oh yeah of course we understand that
it's just going to be I mean we could
say in the car if need be this is our
private property well I mean you're
right to privacies I mean we respect his
right to privacy yeah of course thank
you for your service
yes thank you for your service by the
way
okay yeah I mean I mean like I have a
time we're gonna go
thank you thank you we're just here to
say a little prayer for the Justice yeah
with the Cross River Church
thank you he didn't mind yeah oh Jesus
and
his decision
and his rights of privacy
and maybe his right to privacy never be
infringed
so say at the Lord
amen amen amen amen
guys this is a joke okay
they're pretend there's people saying
these guys are losers this is a joke
they're just pretending to be
Evangelical Christians
and maybe even that loving versus
Virginia so you could finally get that
divorce we all know you're scared of
your Missus and this is your master plan
Hallelujah
thank you very much
okay
I would have never got that [ __ ] took
my black ass
I want to get out and say stuff like
that like oh yeah
the the boys having a grand old time and
uh they're they're really there's a lot
of people doing some really good stuff
Walter Masterson we have to shout out
the guys over at the good liars
including I've been told one guy is DAV
Ram Stifler
and the other guy and uh our own Luke
Beasley who was also at the Trump uh
event over the weekend so really really
great stuff okay we're about to get our
9 p.m results tons of people just dumped
in memberships on my website I'm gonna
try to thank every single one of them
real quick thanks to Joshua adger you
were new member number 50 you get a free
item
please email info davidpackman.com to
collect Derek Ramos is a new member Eric
Johnston is a new member
Glenn Barb is a new member Kevin
Anderson just signed up Kurt Reese is a
new member Betsy Hibbert has just signed
up that's six putting us at 56 and then
I got a bunch of gifts to give away here
Mark Davis just gifted a subscription on
my website oh hold on we've got a
projection
welcome back to CNN election night in
America we can now make a major
projection
see you then projects that John
fetterman the lieutenant governor of
Pennsylvania Dave Wasserman called it 40
minutes ago we already all knew that
Senate primary beating his leading
opponent Congressman Connor that's right
Federman locking up the nomination on
the same day that he had a pacemaker
implanted after suffering a stroke just
days ago fetterman will face the winner
of Pennsylvania's Republican Senate
primary for the seat now held by
retiring Republican senator Pat Toomey
let's go to Jessica Dino who's at
betterment headquarters in Pittsburgh
Jessica a very important day in the life
of John fetterman
Happy Feet
together yeah he's had a lot happen in
the last not even 12 hours Jake he had
that pacemaker put in just a short time
ago coming out of that procedure at 6 PM
it's now what roughly 9 p.m on the east
coast and they just found out here that
John fetterman is going to be the
Democratic nominee for this senate seat
it is an open senate seat in
Pennsylvania it's where Democrats are
really hoping to pick up a seat in the
Senate and keep control understand this
is the man whose race could determine do
Democrats or Republicans control the
senate for the next two years Lancaster
at his hospital room tonight recovering
from that procedure he suffered a stroke
on Friday that took him off the trail
for five days we're told he's doing very
well after his procedure that he is
expected to make a full recovery that he
will be hitting the campaign trail soon
Jake but we're not exactly sure when
soon will be he still has to be released
from the hospital and his wife Giselle
told me yesterday she wants at least a
week of him getting extra rest beyond
what the doctors are ordering him to do
now speaking of his wife she is here
with their children we're expecting to
hear from her in a little bit she's
going to be standing in as the candidate
tonight it's unclear if we'll be hearing
from the lieutenant governor whether
virtually or a message of some sort but
we are expecting to hear from her wife
as she thinks supporters here in
Pittsburgh where he thought he would be
tonight Jake but instead he is now the
Democratic Senate nominee uh from a
hotel room in Lancaster Jake all right
Jessica Dean uh and at fighterman and
Campaign Headquarters uh let's go to
Dana Bash and Abby Phillip and Abby you
and I were talking about this earlier uh
all right so we we got that projection
from Dave Wasserman 40 minutes ago but
we're continuing to watch it Madison
cawthorne I want to alert everybody is
closing in you just saw at the bottom
right of the screen there and we can
even take a closer look at it
um here it is the lead for cawthorne is
now down to only
3.6 points with 77 percent of the vote
this is going to potentially come down
to the wire
I really want to see Madison cawthorne
lose he is the worst of the worst of the
worst and prompt endorsed him and we we
just really want to see him lose okay so
that lead has shrunk it's shriveling
it's experiencing shrinkage all the way
down to 3.6 percent
with 77 of the vote
um
so we're going to be if cawthorne loses
tonight we're gonna have to play some of
his greatest hits for sure so that's
extraordinarily good news okay uh what
else do we have here I missed a couple
of super chats let me go back up I
apologize and see if I can find them uh
how do I sign up for a gift subscription
okay easy you just go to joinpakman.com
and when you go through the process wait
how do you do you want a gift money or
you want to give a gift
if you want to request one you go to
davidpackman.com free membership and
fill out the form
okay
that is uh that is it
um thanks to Mellow Melly Cambell Andy
Yamashiro Grass Valley Greg for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
61 I also want to make sure everybody
who gifted a subscription gets a thank
you so that includes Alexandra Zahn
Stanley minarik
Beth Rothman
Christopher farmer that's four plus the
one I mentioned before is five so that's
65 and I am pleased to announce that
I don't even know how to pronounce this
gets a free membership Shane Smalley
gets a free membership Brian Torres gets
a free membership Johnny Road gets a
free membership and uh Bray Grissom gets
a free membership very much appreciate
that and then lastly Lisa calendar just
got herself a membership that's number
66 uh very very big exciting things
going on
um
okay
let's look at
actually do we want to do that now I
don't know that we do let's listen to a
couple voicemails that are coming in
here
um
Okay let's listen
voicemail well hello David backman this
is the clans's clod Hopper calling it's
evening here in Arlington Kansas I was
watching some of your Clips here off of
your live
and it's the creepiest tweet of all time
is the title and you're asking what are
these people doing is this summoning is
this Gregorian chant
a few other things that I didn't get
jotted down real quick but as much as I
enjoy your show David I'm kind of
tickled uh what they're doing is
reciting the rosary and they're doing it
as a group
so let's recite it out loud uh go online
check it out it's called the rosary it's
a common form of Prayer in the Catholic
church and it's often done in groups
good to know Hey listen Chris Wallace is
on CNN I don't I mean I don't watch TV
but has he been on there much before
versal background checks he wants to end
the filibuster he wants to legalize pot
and interestingly enough for a
progressive he's also going to have an
issue he's going to have to deal with
the black community because of the mayor
of Braddock Pennsylvania in 2013 he was
out one night and heard some what he
said was gunfire and ended up
confronting an unarmed black jogger uh
with a shotgun and it it nothing came of
it wait who did that turned out the
fella was unarmed in fact the man is now
in jail and he's endorsing veterans from
jail oh my God but you can understand
how a republican candidate could work
with that uh to try to to hurt fetterman
in the world did Chris Wallace say
fetterman confronted a black man who was
jogging fetterman had a shotgun the guy
want went to jail and endorsed fetterman
from jail that's that's an insane story
when he was mayor dear God I have never
heard that before because some of the
things that make him uh more appealing
the unconventionality as you point out
may not play as well uh in those areas
but I do think that when you look at the
poll the CNN poll that we heard earlier
the two people they're friends now
that's wild huh blur about politics I do
think what what what what uh what
everyone has said that authenticity and
and sort of unconventionality
this may be a year with that plays yeah
but issues matter too
sure yes they do Depends they do and you
could see a lot of people concerned is
Chris Wallace playing the right wing
voice something about this is feeling
like I don't know that I understand
Chris Wallace's kind of like uh
role here in his favor it you know given
depending on what the Supreme Court does
I mean to me what's so interesting about
this particular race is the Conor lamb
as I think Dana was saying is sort of on
paper the perfect candidate right the
perfect candidate there's a marine yeah
every prosecutor uh he's he spent you
know two and a half million dollars
which normally would be okay fetterman
spent six million dollars but um he you
know in this focus group my poster was
telling me about he doesn't come all
right well we're going to continue
monitoring the numbers there
um let's listen to voicemail here's a
voicemail about Pennsylvania
hey David ahead of this uh
election Pennsylvania what are your
thoughts on it Philly cheesesteaks I
think it's kind of overrated as the
sandwich
category but you let me know oh uh at
the risk of losing all of my supporters
um from from Philadelphia
I think the Philly cheese steak is a
very overrated sandwich very very
overrated sandwich and the other thing
is it's kind of just a mess and I'm not
fan of a fan of of
um these sandwiches where it's like kind
of part of the Goof is that it's it's
like a super messy sandwich let me show
you a like a picture of what we're
talking about here I believe it is one
of the most overrated sandwiches out
there
look at that I mean it's like
I I just I it's it's not for me it's
it's gonna be a no for me dog and I've
had plenty of Philly cheesesteaks it's
just not very exciting oftentimes
they're using like it's not even cheese
it's a processed cheese product
um
it's just uh I I just don't know guys
listen I love Philadelphia I love the
people of Pennsylvania
but it's a bit of a trash sandwich yeah
I don't I don't I don't like it a lot of
times also the meat they use it's
extremely fibrous and I don't the last
thing I want when I'm it's it's similar
meat to a French dip although I believe
the French dip is a little bit more
refined but that's you know maybe a bit
of an elitist comment to make when you
bite and then you've got to do this
thing where you pull and like a foot of
shaved steak comes off and then you've
got to rip it no it's just it's a no
okay it's it's enough the French dip is
a little bit messy too I know I know
um the French dip is prime rib oh okay
well it it seems similar to me I don't
know anyway yeah let's let's move on
because it's such we want to raise up
Pennsylvania tonight not take it down
but it's a very overrated sandwich
very overrated sandwich
uh let's see what other thoughts people
had on the
um
election
stuff happening
um let's see
hey Dave the soy sauce boss listen
Brian David Bruce calling from Kentucky
the reality issue
do you hang up Trump for no reason
he he was a huge influence on America
he's got pretty much perfect body what
and gray had a hair
I think you're jealous
because you're smaller
anyways David all right I think that
that probably is a joke I don't know
it's very very strange
um
yeah
okay we're gonna I think we're gonna get
away from that because that's
that's getting a little bit weird Okay
um someone in the chat says that the
bond me is it actually a good sandwich
that is absolutely true
and in fact
one of the best Bond memes that I've had
if I understand correctly the oranges of
the ban me are of course Vietnamese but
it's a it's a sandwich on French bread
and you might say wait hold on why
French bread in Vietnam yes go look at
the colonial history of France and
Vietnam okay
um the the best Bond me I've ever had in
Montreal
Quebec Canada
okay a place I will very soon be
spending large amounts of time in
Montreal Quebec Canada you go to the
Atwater Market
and you go to the Vietnamese
food stall
and you get yourself the grilled chicken
ban me
I don't know that I've ever had
a better sandwich
equal equal
okay
that's where I would go uh
uh the Vietnamese food stand at Atwater
Market in Montreal thank you very much
everybody okay whatever happened to
Pedro from Colombia I don't know he just
hasn't been calling in lately
terrible opinion sir do you dislike
tacos too basically the same food no
tacos I like tacos I like
Booker out of Kentucky won the
Democratic Senate nomination I did see
that an important race he will face Rand
Paul
why are you trying to start a war on
sandwiches it's just my opinion it's
just my opinion that's all all right
let's get an update on the Madison
cawthorne numbers because I'm getting oh
no look at how close this is getting
with 81 reporting we are down to a 2.4
percent uh uh deficit for Madison
cawthorne he may still pull this out
damn it
all we can do is wait
all we can do is wait over on the
Republican side Mehmet has closed the
Gap Mehmet who was initially very much
behind has now closed the Gap it's only
4.8 that separates him from the leader
Dave McCormick so this is uh these both
of these races are changing
significantly significantly and we've
got to monitor them closely I love
watching centrists on Twitter meltdown
tonight great stuff but David is
perfectly purposely trying to hurt
feelings right now
Centrist what is this person talking
about
centrists are melting down what does
that mean
I don't even know what that means
Keith says have you ever had a cheese
steak in Philadelphia if so where I have
I don't remember where
it was so long ago so long ago
I just don't remember I want to say
thank you to Laura Gerard Laura just
made a pledge on patreon guys patreon
pledges count double tonight
every patreon pledge tonight counts as
two
that's an executive decision let me
thank just a couple of other people
thanks to Kaylee Nichols for gifting a
subscription
thanks to Nick Ammons for gifting a
subscription we're continuing to watch
those numbers out of Pennsylvania thanks
to Phil McCracken I I don't care guys
it's a gift subscription I'll say it
Lisa calendar has gifted another one
those are four gifts putting us at 72
the recipients of those gifts are Ronald
corcos Brandi Grissom June heard and
Diana George also thank you to Mitch
Bernay
and Brian lamadu
new member 73 and 74. I really
appreciate everybody's support and also
thanks to the old tired Road and Bowflex
man for the twitch Prime subscriptions
David sir I read somewhere not liking a
Cheesesteak is an early symptom of
sociopathy maybe think about that early
I mean it okay that's kind of weird
but I will uh I'll take it I guess
a big strong man came up to me crying
and he said sir sir when will you save
America so we can eat Philly cheese
steak sandwiches again I know they don't
really talk about that they don't really
talk about that
Chief State commentary was spot on yeah
it's honestly guys it's not even
controversial Philly cheesesteak is just
not that great oh by the way anybody
talking about roast beef leave the
stream I don't want to hear a word about
roast beef roast beef is arguably the
worst cold cut
yeah I mean listen you've got Pastrami
and you've got corned beef those are
Peak
okay you've got like 10 things in
between
and then you've got roast beef at the
bottom bottom of the barrel guys roast
beef net
roast beef is like saying let's go
Brandon in the chat it's an instaban
okay that's a joke moderators by the way
we're not really Banning anybody we're
just we're just having a good time all
right let's look at a couple of other
listen to a couple other voicemails here
people coming in
um
about the election
although I'm not finding anything super
interesting to play for you guys
let's see hi David
I don't know if you heard the other day
uh May 16th show on Dan bongino
he talked about the Buffalo shooter and
wanted to get to the bottom the motives
and he didn't want to take the great
replacement Theory as one of the motives
he just didn't accept that it's crazy
you know we have all these shootings
where it's like a you know a
murder-suicide and the shooter leaves no
note and everybody goes I don't know I
mean he was the nicest guy just quiet
got along well with everybody
I don't know we don't have any it's just
it's it'll be it'll be a mystery we take
to our grave because we we just don't I
just don't know we never know this guy
leaves a hundred page Manifesto telling
you exactly why he did it and Dan
bongino is like oh why did he do it we
just don't know it's not clear not real
but then proceeded to double down on the
reset Theory and he cites that article
from 2018 by the New York Times called
uh we can replace them and just keeps
continuing to spout that headline
article and not even discuss what is in
the article unbelievable anyways I'm
curious to see if you've heard about it
I didn't hear about that now but it's
not it's not surprising
Bronx Bjorn says next you're going to
tell a sign Feld is better than Frasier
oh my God I can't get through a single
episode of Frasier I I know every
Seinfeld episode by heart people want to
send me honestly if people want to send
me Seinfeld trivia like real Seinfeld
trivia uh via Super Chat I will prove my
Seinfeld Bona fides roast beef is
mediocre at best it's the turkey of dark
Meats absolutely
I worked at a cheesesteak shop for four
years I could make you a delicious
sandwich David quit hating I'm not
denying that you can make a cheese steak
sandwich that's fine it's just it's just
not for me okay
uh Cheesesteak is made it best how can
anyone be that attached to the 579th
best sandwich out there key race alert
folks any race alerts for you now with
CNN's election night in America take a
look at this in the Senate Republican
primary former hedge fund CEO Dave
McCormick still in the lead with 31.9 of
the vote he's almost 7 000 votes ahead
of Mehmet Oz the TV Doctor Who has
Trump's endorsement with 28.2 percent in
third place as of right now Firebrand
Kathy Barnett who has
22.1 of the vote again McCormick in the
lead right now by about 7 000 votes with
only 14 of the vote in still a lot of
votes to count in the Senate Republican
primary in Pennsylvania let's look at
the gubernatorial primary right now and
look at that Doug mastriano
who is Trump endorsed has taken a strong
lead he has now 35.8 percent of the vote
that's not more than 26 000 votes ahead
of former Congressman Lou Barletta who
has 21.7 percent of the vote Bill
McSwain the former U.S attorney has 17.1
percent of the vote businessman Dave
White 9.5 of the vote Doug mastriano the
Trump endorsed candidate has skyrocketed
ahead of the competitors although there
is still only I think when they say
Firebrand they mean no actual relevant
qualifications to speak of right that's
how I'm interpreting Firebrand person
with no qualifications and Congressman
Madison cawthorne has closed the Gap
with state Senator Chuck Edwards who is
still in the league people keep saying
that there will be a runoff okay so look
at this soup look at this uh Super Chat
Madison in North Carolina will go to a
runoff a candidate needs 30 but they
they both have thirty percent so I don't
I don't know that I'm understanding the
rule exactly let's see if we can find it
North Carolina House runoff rule
okay runoff rules let's take a look at
what it says let's let's actually
let's digest the text if we can
okay I guess I've got to allow ads
that's too bad
okay oh my God this is why I don't do
ads look at this
all right in order to win a primary race
and be guaranteed a spot on the general
election ballot candidates must reach a
certain threshold okay
there's a threshold in a primary
candidates must win more than 30 percent
of the vote in their race to secure the
nomination that means 30 percent plus
one
what if they don't receive more than 30
okay well they they both have more than
thirty percent so that doesn't apply
so I don't understand it it's
if they why would there be a runoff
they they have the thirty percent I
don't
is it that if two people get 30 then I
I'm not even understanding why
everybody's saying the current results
would be a runoff Chuck Edwards has 30
plus one and he has a plurality
so I'm not sure if somebody can explain
I just don't see how the current results
mean there would be a runoff
um okay
that when we dealt with that one thanks
to Jojo phantasma for the twitch Prime
subscription your number 77 and I want
to give away some more free memberships
look at this Lisa Rader sending a gift
Nick Ammons sending a gift Nick Ammon
sending another gift and Nick Ammon
sending another gift Nick Ammons with
another gift Nick Ammons with another
gift and Nick Ammons with another gift
guys that's seven gifts that's 84 and
I'm gonna give them away we just go in
order okay Philip Lovelace number one
Stephanie Brewer
rudis kaisals
Lis Le live
Jordan B
tanmay Kulkarni and Magdalena Tavares if
you want a free membership go to
davidpackman.com free membership if you
can gift a membership go to
joinpakman.com and check that this is a
gift box during checkout but most
importantly most importantly get
yourself a membership you can use the
coupon code Obama Obama and you'll see
that that drops it
dramatically
dramatically and if you decide to go
monthly which is fine it's fine you can
do the coupon code monthly as well Obama
and look at this I'm not even going to
say it out loud because my lawyer will
beat down the door and tell me it's too
cheap
it's too cheap okay
um let's continue with a couple other
voicemails coming in
let's see here
hi David I'm a little I'm just annoyed
again I'm annoyed again and I don't know
what it is it's just consistent that
Republicans or conservatives or both
mispronounce and misspell words
frequently it's so annoying they can't
pronounce kamala's name correctly uh
your clip of Charlie course said Kabul
it's Kabul right guys it's Kabul why
can't Republicans open a book and learn
how to pronounce something correctly
yeah they're so eager to get on camera
and start yelling but then they don't
want to find out how to pronounce words
correctly they want to act and I look I
try to watch conservative news to be
bipart yeah no it's crazy a rhino named
Mick reimney I would never do that by
the way anybody see tool C gabbard on
the Tucker show the other night it was
it was pretty wacky wacky stuff a couple
other voicemails coming in let's see
what else we've got here
hey David I'm watching the
um live stream review right now about
Pennsylvania and whatnot and they're
saying like oh this person is Trump
endorsed um is and Biden hasn't come out
to endorse anyone is it not normal for a
president to come out and endorse
um a candidate
chat can correct me if I'm wrong about
this
I don't believe it's typical that a
current or former president would be
making this many primary endorsements in
a midterm election correct me if I'm
wrong I don't recall it I don't remember
Obama doing it I don't remember Bush
doing it I don't remember Clinton doing
it I I just have no it doesn't seem
normal to me
at all
David sir will you give a happy birthday
shout out to my fur baby boo-boo love
your show uh sure what is is Booboo a
cat
uh Happy Birthday to boo boo
very very exciting day
um
yeah
couple others and another thing these
Republicans love these characters that
we talk about the Madison Hawthorns and
the Laura boberts and the Marjorie
Taylor green they love these people they
think these people are fighting up
against tyranny and these are the sort
of the stupidest people on the face of
the planet that represent our people in
the United States and These Guys these
guys think these guys are brilliant
because they get on cameras and they say
things aggressively without evidence
without context without it's so dumb yep
yep very very well said
very well said
um Mehmet Oz has pulled almost even with
Dave McCormick he may still pull it out
here's some Seinfeld trivia this is
really difficult trivia the George heart
attack episode what Jordan what surgery
does George actually need
uh tonsillectomy I believe George needs
a tonsillectomy
how much does Jerry tell him it will
cost
1500
and how much does Kramer tell him a
holistic healer will cost
is it 50 bucks can anybody fact check me
is it tonsillectomy 1550 dollars
anybody these those are those are like
really specific Seinfeld trivia
questions can anybody fact check it
nobody knows okay
gallbladder
I thought it was the tonsillectomy
tonsils and adenoids or something like
that am I mixing up the episodes
those are extremely difficult questions
we'd have to like look at a script quite
frankly to figure that out
okay fair enough all right
okay let's uh let's move on voicemails
continue to come in
roast beef
what's the dinner all right a pro roast
beef phone call hi David it's Drew I
just voted in Pennsylvania the member on
your website for a little while yeah so
I was part of that exit poll
um that they were doing on the way out
of the Allegheny election in our county
office and I needed a point to tell them
that it seemed like Connor ran his race
as though he was running against Donald
Trump and that people were not going to
be able to stand on him because he's
running against another candidate
instead of running on his own policy
um
Chris Wallace seems to be really
confused about that even though he's
talking about all the policymatics
he seems to think it doesn't clearly all
right so when a Pennsylvania voter and
roast um roast beef and exit poll not a
roast beef participant uh an exit poll
participant very very important
um Nettles says David sir what do you
think is the minimum amount of student
loan debt that Biden could forgive that
would have an impact on the midterms I
think if Biden forgave 15 grand in
student loan debt I think it would
impact the midterms
um
yeah
what do people think I think 15 grand 15
grand is a lot of money
uh as a percentage of a lot of people
student loan debt I know some people
have hundreds of thousands of dollars
but a lot of people don't
and I think if he did 15 grand it would
start to have an impact not as much as
maybe it could
it would be life-changing for a lot of
people that's exactly right
what magazine is George reading when his
mom catches him in the ACT oh damn it's
something relatively benign uh
is it l
e l l e is that the magazine George is
reading glamor oh it's glamor I think
you guys are right yeah
these are these are tough questions
these are tough questions
trivia what's the first fake name George
Goes by okay I remember Art Van delay
at one point I know he thinks of art
core delay but is there something even
earlier than Art Van delay
I think there might be
but I don't remember
I know a lot of people are saying Art
Van delay but I don't I don't know that
it is I remember an early episode where
he pretends to be I believe an architect
where he might have gone by a different
name
yeah
yeah that's these are good questions all
right we are back folks it's alert we're
flipping Pennsylvania with 22 of the
vote and you have uh McCormick at
31.9 commandment Oz at 29.5 and Kathy
Barnett at 22.9 uh also now in the race
for governor in Pennsylvania you have
Doug mastriano at 41.2 Lou Barletta 22.2
Bill McSwain at 15.1 and Dave White at
8.2 again with 22 percent of the vote
now in let's go to what to uh Melanie
zanona at mastriano headquarters in
Chambersburg Pennsylvania so I am
getting very very nervous about this
Madison cawthorne race it is now a it's
down to 2.1 oh guys it's almost over
we're at 98 of the vote and Madison
cawthorne may have been defeated please
please hold the Applause hold on I'm
coming whoa whoa whoa Donald wait wait
hold on a second Donald
um it is not yet over
it is not yet over but it is close
Madison cawthorne is losing and he may
be removed forcibly
from the people's house which would be
unbelievable
I'm about to sue every machine guy we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines uh that let's not get ahead of
ourselves let's not get there's still
2.9 uh 1.9 of the vote to go let's wait
VJ says tonsillectomy was correct
surgery was four grand holistic healer
was 38 bucks you were close David thank
you
uh if two can't oh here's the rule North
Carolina okay if two candidates receive
a substantial plurality the candidate
receiving the highest vote shall be
declared the nominee according to that
there's no runoff Okay let's listen
especially what was going to happen in
Pennsylvania actually I'm going to
refill my water I'll be back in five and
the president is already previewing what
the message is going to look like no
matter who it is is that John fetterman
is running against when it comes to the
Republican side of this as we still wait
to see with the results and that are
going to look like and he says that he
does believe fetterman can win in
November and the reason he says that
Anderson is because while we await the
results of the GOP Primary one thing is
clear these candidates are not your
father's GOP they have fought a
malicious chaotic primary campaign to be
the most extreme and they've shown
people their authentic selves that
whoever emerges will be the dangerous to
Craven and too extreme to represent
pennsylvanians in the United States
Senate Anderson that goes back to this
message that you've heard emanating from
the White House in recent days as the
president has invoked this term Ultra
Maga that he has been using to describe
the party something the White House
believes is going to be a negative point
for them to use though of course
loyalists of the former president say
they believe that that is not the dig
that the White House thinks it is but it
does show you that the way the White
House is going to frame this no matter
if it's Dave McCormick who wins Dr Oz or
of course Barnett in this race in
Pennsylvania
yeah Kim Collins the White House thanks
we'll check in with you a little bit
later van Jones is this Democratic line
going to work in Pennsylvania I don't
know if it's going to work but it's an
authentic thing I I do think that
Democrats are looking at a Republican
party and with a lot of fear uh this is
not at least it's not your your father
this is not a normal party at all to
have uh the idea that mastriano who's a
part of the Insurrection could be the
governor of the state appoint the
Secretary of State to overturn the
election results that's even possible in
America it's shocking and I think the
president is authentically trying to
sound that alarm he's trying to to raise
the stakes a little bit because if you
just you know if you just say well you
know I'm mad I'm frustrated I like gas
prices I'm gonna sit home you can lose
your democracy I think the president
wants people to know that so so again
let's just remember it's a Republican
primary it's not a general election
right so I wouldn't get too too carried
away about it and uh and we'll see
though we got a lot we got a lot of
election going on still here we'll see
you know it'll be interesting if John if
Doug mastriano wins and and Dave
McCormick wins what message is that
sound right because because clearly
there are two completely different
candidates we should point out your uh
donor I'm a supporter donor friend
you've given advice to them as well
what does it say to you that he is in
the lead right right now there was a lot
of talk about Kathy Barnett coming up uh
that does maybe seems to have been
somewhat overblown although again it's
very early 2012. again Anderson I think
Pennsylvania's are smart they want to
elect the most conservative person they
can win in the fall and in the senate
race it's clear I think that's it's much
clearer in a senate race where there's
less candidates there were there were 14
candidates in the governor's race to
begin with right down to a a a pretty
still pretty big stable and the Senate
racing really came down to these three
candidates and Dave McCormick was the
most authentic the most conservative
that people think could win in the fall
and I think that's what we're just
saying right now but what's interesting
with mastriano and the Trump endorsement
there is it has bearings for 2024. if
this is a winnable potential pickup for
the GOP in Pennsylvania and if he
endorsed somebody who in my opinion does
not have a shot that could end up
hurting Trump's viability in 2024 and
you've seen other potential candidates
back others in this race but I think the
question to Van Jones's point is is
crazy going to win tonight uh
respectfully and I think the fact that
McCormick is actually ahead shows that
the voters may be more animated by what
looks like competent leadership somebody
who has the experience to take on the
issues inflation economy
Etc that are really animating voters
there was a lot of Buzz around Barnett
but it looks like she's trailing at this
point so I think we will see where this
goes I like these are crazy respect
I I don't want to count any chickens
before they hatch but I am genuinely
excited at the possibility that
cawthorne might lose we are now up to
98.7 percent of the vote in and the lead
shrank again to now just 1.9 percentage
points but cawthorne is still uh oh
it just went down to 96 uh we were
almost there but now it just went down
that's not so good
huh it's weird
it would be amazing if he lost I mean
he's been in office 16 months and for
him to already lose it would be
delightful just just it would be a
delight I don't know how else to say it
um
okay
so we're going to a little bit of a
break let's continue looking at some
things here art vandelay Seinfeld second
episode from the Stakeout very good
in the spirit of Madison cawthorne I to
my fellow gay friends call him kind of a
cute Nazi what episode does George
Costanza say this line
kind of a cute Nazi okay so who there's
a woman
oh okay the episode where
um George gets into the limo of a white
supremacist and there's a woman in the
limo and George starts to think she's
cute and they're like George she's a
Nazi and George says but she's kind of a
cute Nazi
that's the episode all right let's
continue the voicemails are pouring in
yes this is Dale Gribble I mean Rusty
Shackleford I was curious if Mike
Lindell is going to sue all machines
including bubble gum machines David I'm
curious is your answer and I hope that
you're not tracking me like the Beast
does
right yep no that's all those are good
points what kind of soup does Newman buy
from The Soup Nazi
um
is it crab bisque
does Newman buy crab bisque or no is it
mulligatani
I think it's Malik Italian jambalaya oh
damn
mulligatani is a hell of a soup it
really is Young Star prod with a 50
dollar Super Chat joined and joined
cheers to the chat and to progression
vote Common Sense hashtag vote blue
thank you and I apologize I've fallen
way behind in thanking people the
freelix remix and star birdie have
grabbed twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 86. look at these numbers
Natalie Barbera is a new member Gladys
Owens is a new member Junior Moreno is a
new member and Selena Garcia
Chris Joseph just signed up so did
Debbie Bruce that puts us at 92.
oh man guys we might we might get there
Nick Ammons just gifted another
membership putting us at 93 and that one
goes to
we've got a duplicate here David Wolfe
gets that free membership we may get it
and we may open up phone lines
momentarily
um
in the meantime yeah I know let's let's
look at the cawthorne numbers
no update yet
still a 1.9 percentage point gap
and in Pennsylvania oh God Oz has pulled
to within two points
ham
it is now oh okay just it just the lead
just grew a little bit for Dave
McCormick to two
it's it's still a fight it's still
anybody's
but uh I'm starting to have a little bit
less
of a confidence about some of these
races
um
we will see
which of the Republican primary
candidates would be most likely to upset
fetterman I think it's McCormick the guy
that's winning quite frankly
how will you celebrate surpassing Dave
Rubin in YouTube subscribers is that
true I didn't know that uh let's see
um
where's Reuben at
Ruben report
oh he has way more subscribers than I do
I'm not even uh
I don't think I will be surpassing him I
do have by the way this is a really
crazy clip hold on where is this thing
um I've got a really weird Dave Rubin
clip I've not actually previewed this
but it was posted to my Reddit that Dave
Rubin was driving around making fun of
homeless people let's see what this is
Hollywood
the Hollywood
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yep okay Dave Rubin driving around
making fun of uh homeless people I guess
that's weird uh yes it is true it is
true that while Dave Rubin uh has more
subscribers than I do I have more than
twice the daily views and really views
are what matter uh let's listen when do
doctors expect him not you I understand
your your cautiousness and you're the
one that made him go to the hospital on
Fridays kudos to you for that but when
did doctors expect him to be well enough
to leave the hospital uh and when do
they think he'll be well enough to
campaign
[Applause]
did I don't have that date yet they said
it a couple days but they didn't give me
a firm date yet um he was under
observation today
um the surgery today the surgery was
great and I think they'll just watch him
and then hopefully we'll have a firm
date when I get him home
so your husband won his race today he
obviously uh has a long campaign ahead
of him before the election in November
do you think his condition is going to
affect his ability to campaign
thank you
I don't you know the more I learn about
the procedure he's had you know over a
million Americans have this done every
year they lead great lives I'm confident
that he'll be able to perform his job
and do a great job and continue to do so
I know this is all very sudden and
you're you're dealing with it in real
time but I know you understand uh the
need for voters to know exactly how he's
doing
um do you think the campaign has been
completely transparent and
can we expect can the voters of
Pennsylvania expect your husband and his
doctor to come and answer any questions
that that reporters might have
[Applause]
absolutely they can I feel that we've
done a great job I mean we turned around
the news
um in under 48 Hours my kids knew just
right before the rest of the world did
and we've been open and transparent
through the whole thing will continue to
be the exciting news to share is that
surgery was perfect and he's well in
enrolled to full recovery
it's still early we still don't know
who's going to win the Republican Senate
primary in Pennsylvania is there a
candidate that your husband would rather
run again McCormick Mehmet Oz uh or Ms
Barnett can't answer that
no I think we'll wait to see what we're
up against and we'll prepare to continue
the trail and continue working for
Pennsylvania until November
your husband has has he in the past he
called himself a progressive now he says
he's not a progressive he claims he's
also not a moderate how do you think his
pitch will be to voters uh policy issues
obviously very important as you know
pennsylvanians like so many Americans
across the country worried about
inflation worried about health care
prices uh worried about health care
access what is his pitch going to be why
should voters vote for him
foreign
who listens he's someone who wants to
understand your issues whether you voted
for him now
or not he wants to be a senator for all
of Pennsylvania so he really cares about
people and he wants to understand what
your needs are what your priorities are
and you know the label of progressive or
not the things he's running now are the
same things he ran back then when they
called them a progressive now it's where
the party has shifted I think he's
someone who's always has been able to
shift the needle on issues and I think
he'll continue to do that he is
passionate about the work that he does
he works on tough issues and he slowly
moves the needle so that he gets others
on board on this work the second Lady of
the great Commonwealth of Pennsylvania
Giselle fetterman congratulations again
I know it's been a wild roller coaster
of a few days for you and your family
but but congratulations on the
hard-fought victory this evening
[Applause]
guys I'd vote for her over any of the
Republican candidates put her up against
Mehmet Oz I'm voting for her uh wow wow
wow oh wait are they back how are your
kids are they they dealing with us all
okay I know it's tough you got three
little kids
[Applause]
they are I mean you know we're a family
like any other family that will have a
health scare that will face it and keep
going the kids are involved in
everything they um kept them in the loop
they know what's happening they've been
to see Daddy they were excited to see
how good he looked and they know that
he's gonna be back out soon so it is a
little hard time for our family but
we'll be back together soon again okay
thank you so much for joining us on this
uh evening uh it's a gonna be a wild day
for the fettermans uh we're watching the
race for the Republican nominee who will
face off against lieutenant governor the
Madison cawthorne race is very close to
being called by Dave Wasserman Dave
Wasserman just tweeted four minutes ago
the rest of Henderson County just
reported Edwards lead over cawthorne
expanded to 1657. cawthorne needs a
miracle we are watching here and it is
over
ladies and gentlemen
oh sorry I froze there I had to be
rebooted I've seen enough Congressman
Madison cawthorne
has lost renomination to State Senator
Chuck Edwards
wow what a humiliating defeat for one of
the biggest clowns in Congress and a
defeat for president Donald Trump let's
put a tweet together
after just 16 months in office
lunatic extremist
vile disgusting retrograde
Republican Madison cawthorne has already
lost his Republican primary
endorsed by
Trump last night
another loss for Trump
wow ladies and gentlemen
it's over cawthorne is going back to I
don't care where he goes he can go
wherever the hell he wants he just can't
stay in the people's house what great
news this could be a disastrous primary
for Democrats it's probably going to be
the other Republican who wins I mean
let's be completely honest but cawthorne
is the worst of the worst of the worst a
loser by trade and he has been removed
very very quickly very very quickly
um
will he say that it was fraud
we'll see
we'll see
um it's going to be very very
interesting
should we do a coupon code to celebrate
I'm game I'm game what should it be
uh let me I'll put together a cawthorne
coupon code just to celebrate
fraud with a W yeah that could be it man
what delightful news what absolutely
whoa 100 likes already
absolutely delightful
um let me go into my coupon element what
should the cothorne
coupon code be cry Thorn that's not bad
Madison cry Thorne I that's I could go
for that
uh maybe it's a bit Petty
any other ideas for the cawthorne coupon
code
I'm about to do it
um
just delightful no
uh man
I'll do I'll do cry thorn
cry Thorn Let's actually make it Madison
cry Thorne and we'll make it good on
any of the memberships and first person
to use it gets a free item from my
online store you just gotta figure out
how to spell it okay the coupon code is
live to celebrate the defeat of Madison
cawthorne you can use the coupon code
Madison crythorne at joinpakman.com
uh Madison cope Thorn would be another
one cocaine orgy could have been another
one what a great bit of news I mean you
just you can't beat it you really can't
beat it let's see if CNN announces it
anytime soon because if there's no doubt
that Dave Wasserman definitely calls
these before the networks typically do
uh stand by for projection let's see
let's see if they call it
[Music]
it's election night in America and CNN
can now make a major projector
let's see CNN projects that Doug
mastriano is the winner of the
Pennsylvania Republican primary for
governor mastriano who received
president Trump's endorsement is a very
vocal advocate of Trump's bogus efforts
to overturn the 2020 election
transference prevails in a crowd this is
extremely important because this guy
could help
Trump or republican steal Pennsylvania
in 2024. this actually is a really big
deal let's see if they talk about it the
Republican nominee for governor of
Pennsylvania somebody who has been one
of the most full-throated supporters of
Donald Trump's lies about the 2020
election yep somebody who actually
supported not counting the votes of
Pennsylvania voters in 2020. I don't
know that we've ever had something like
this in a a dynamic like this or you
have a nominee for governor who will of
course appoint the Secretary of State in
charge of the state elections dangerous
who has a position of having wanted to
disenfranchise all of his Commonwealth's
voters in the previous presidential
election indeed right there are
Republicans who are going along with
Donald Trump's election lies because
they see it as advantageous to their
candidacies or to their hold on power if
they're here in Washington and there are
those who were in it from the jump and
that is exactly exactly who Doug
mastriano who CNN is projecting to be
the nominee for governor in in
Pennsylvania is extremely dangerous
extremely dangerous because they've got
basically
one
one slice short of an insurrectionist
loaf of bread as the nominee so that's
going to be a very important race in
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania actually could
could determine so many different things
in November and that's why we're
watching it so closely
um and we will we will see let's see if
we have updated numbers here
the lease the lead is holding at right
around two points for Dave McCormick
over Mehmet Oz but again the big news if
you were just joining us Madison
cawthorne has been defeated has been
defeated has been defeated a major major
defeat for Maga trumpism by any name you
want to assign to it and that's a really
great thing
David since we already missed cawthorne
can we do a prediction on who's leading
in the next 15 or 30 minutes Oz or
opponents it would seem to be Peak
content right now uh okay yeah let's do
it let me get this set up so we're going
to do
who will let's see who will lead PA GOP
Senate
at let's call it 10 15 p.m Eastern
and it will be
McCormick or
Oz all right we're gonna get that going
you can vote on YouTube let's get it
going on Twitch as well
McCormick or Oz
and we will start that we'll make it a
five-minute vote who do you believe the
numbers right now are McCormick
32.1 Mehmet 30.1 at 10 15 PM Eastern
meaning 14 minutes from now who will be
winning
on YouTube
85 percent of you believe that
McCormick's lead will hold
on Twitch 80 percent of you believe that
McCormick's lead will hold but that is
shrinking that is shrinking
uh we will know in 15 minutes we'll run
these polls uh for about five in the
meantime we just had an absolutely huge
dump of memberships they call them dumps
and I want to thank some really great
people Rachel Weiss with a new
membership Cameron Titus has signed up
Matthew Coppola is a new member Tiffany
Knott has signed up
Jean-Pierre gamara is a new member
Catherine brandes
hold on let me let me get these things
done one at a time uh Kyle Marlowe
and Lisa hammacher that's eight putting
us at 101 also want to say thanks to
Scott LaBrie for gifting a membership
and Peter divincenzo
Rachel Weiss also with a gift Austin
Crager with a gift
and Junior Moreno with a gift that puts
us at 106 the five gifts go to Becky
danu Nancy Horrigan Canadian maple
Jeffrey thurwatcher and Sandra Sally
lastly thanks to David Roman for the
website membership your number 107 and
then I also want to say thank you to
Dango in Candlelight K Ramsey and
blueberry babe for the twitch Prime
subscriptions
uh oh and also thanks to scooter mix
scoots for the twitch Prime very much
appreciate that what a day Madison
cawthorne has been defeated and it is
delightful news just delightful news we
are celebrating that with the coupon
code Madison crythorne Madison crythorne
let me even put it in the Box above me
Madison
cry thorn
there it is Madison crythorn uh because
we are rejoicing in the fact that one of
the worst people in the house lost
that's good news okay
on the polling question who will lead
the Pennsylvania Republican Senate race
at 10 15 PM Eastern 85 percent of you on
YouTube believe it will be Dave
McCormick
and 75 percent of you on Twitch believe
it will be Dave McCormick
I believe it will also be Dave McCormick
that's at least my hope although the
lead has just shrunk to its smallest of
the evening
oh it was supposed to be a prediction oh
hold on let me let me see if I can end
this
uh how do I do a prediction
Channel points
God
anybody know how to set up a prediction
on Twitch
prediction oh okay
here we go
um
uh okay here we go uh
uh who will lead PA GOP Senate at 10 15
PM Eastern so this you'd have to go over
to Twitch to vote on this
McCormick or Oz and we'll make it a five
minute
GOP Senate
at 10 15 PM Eastern okay there we go
starting the prediction
okay and go beautiful we've got it going
okay now now we're actually doing it
let's get back over here to CNN standing
by for the speech the governorship of
Pennsylvania and we're waiting for Doug
mastriano he's about to speak there uh
we'll hear what mastriano has to say
shortly we'll we'll hear what he's
saying uh we're about to I like this
Super Chat Will trump just ignore that
cawthorne ever existed after tonight
Juni you know I love you that's so good
I'm stealing it and I'm tweeting it I'm
literally copy pasting that's such a
great tweet I I really appreciate the
content uh suggestion beautifully done
beautifully beautifully done
um Seinfeld trivia what's the name of
the ventriloquist dummy Kramer owned oh
I don't remember and since it ran across
the room when Jerry was trying to sleep
in Kramer's apartment was it alive
I I really don't remember that
Mr Marbles okay
you guys remember that better than I do
yeah that's that's uh Fair absolutely
Fair thank you to Betty siemers for the
uh website membership you are number 112
and also want to say thank you to
Stanley minarik for gifting another
subscription on the website that's
number 113. that subscription goes to
Rob motto
I said we would hear from a few people
in the audience if we got to 100 new
members let's do that I'll take a couple
calls via Discord here until the
speeches begin
uh you can go to davidpackman.com
Discord
if you would like to say something uh oh
you know what Juni is actually waiting
to chat Juni is it okay that I stole
your Super Chat and tweeted it out is
that okay
that's okay do you hear me David yes I
do
did you say yes yes I do
okay great great yes yes uh no no it's
great I feel
I'm very honored that you
I'm such a huge
you remember the last time that I called
you by any chance you know not offhand
uh I called you like a couple of I think
a couple of months ago okay but for some
reason when I called you I couldn't hear
you on the other line until it just kind
of seemed like I just you know
interrupted you constantly on the other
uh line of the phone so yeah I feel very
bad about that I'm sorry no problem
apology accepted
okay great great and so um my question
for you is um okay so Madison cawthorn
obviously lost today yes uh hopefully
the the first of many hopefully Oz will
lose as well
um where do you see the direction of the
GOP after tonight if you know with both
of those losses and going into the you
know going into the midterms in the fall
well I think we it's too early to say if
a bunch of these trumpists get knocked
off in primaries I think it's going to
reinforce the anti-trump wing and it
might even dissuade Trump from running
in 24. it's just so early you know we're
happy about the cawthorne loss but this
guy on screen mastroiani who's a trump
lunatic he won and it's still very early
right right that's so true because I
just don't really see uh where the GOP
goes after like after Trump I kind of
feel like they kind of just die out once
Trump is gone because you know I don't
really see the santis or anybody else uh
has that like weird Trump Charisma that
can carry the GOP in the future at least
in my opinion we will have to wait and
see but I think I think DeSantis could
possibly Step Up
yeah I can see that I just don't see him
as like I guess charismatic As Trump is
at least just in my personal opinion but
uh who knows you're right but you know
we'll see what the future holds so we
will Juni always a pleasure
thank you sir and enjoy the rest of your
night sir thank you I appreciate that
there's Juni from Chicago we are going
to hear from one of the winners here
let's check in
we oh no Mehmet Oz is now only down by
1.4 he is he is closing in he is closing
in and I don't like what I see here at
all it's going very much in the wrong
direction let's check in with Haley from
Georgia Haley welcome
hey David hey how are you
I'm great how are you I'm doing well
thank you
so uh from the standpoint of mobilizing
for votes yes
um the right still seems very confused
that Biden won the election even though
he was in the basement right well they
don't seem confused they just don't
believe it yeah because we weren't
rallying like Trump was yeah there were
you know people were uh the boaters and
the bikers and everybody you know yeah
um but we we proved our point seven
million times over right I would say so
yeah do you think that
um we should still push for more rallies
coming up I mean I mean even this year
or in 2024 will the abortion issue push
us further where we don't really have to
do that much or was it simply a Biden
versus Trump thing all else being equal
I'm always up for rallies I want rallies
I want people Gathering I want people
you know uniting and activating and all
of those things all else being equal so
yeah no I don't think now is the time to
stop activating right yeah I've been um
trying to contact uh the Democratic
party in Georgia all of the people that
run the party in my County
um in the state I even contacted both of
my Senators
um I only got a call back from John
ossoff's office really but I've been
trying to organize here in Augusta
Georgia yeah all right well Georgia
votes on is it May 24th is it next
Tuesday
correct yes well we're going to be
watching that very closely Haley yeah
I'm gonna be doing early voting with my
seven-year-old son this week so he he
loves to go and push the buttons and
that's totally legal right
yeah okay good beautiful all right Haley
good let's hope we have some favorable
results in Georgia next week
yes thank you all right thank you there
is Haley from Georgia with a very
powerful call we're standing by here
momentarily for mastriano
um let's speak to
uh oh I don't know let's see what's up
with Cliff from Seattle Cliff what's
going on
hi David uh do you hear me I do I do
great
um yeah I'm so cool to uh see you uh on
a time of day when I can join uh but uh
it's it's strange I feel uh out of what
I can do because I live in a pretty
Progressive area and my uh
representative is really great
um my senators are okay it's uh what do
you recommend for those of us that live
on in these uh Progressive hot beds that
uh
just have to sort of hope that the rest
of the country doesn't spiral downward
too far you can phone bank for
absolutely any race you're interested in
you know just just you could just pick a
race that matters you could say I think
Pennsylvania said it's going to be the
Difference Maker I'll phone bank there
for fetterman you know you can you can
do that
is that one what we would recommend I
mean I'm guessing once we come to the
general Pennsylvania is going to be
pretty yeah I mean listen I think I
think we should wait but my instinct is
Pennsylvania is going to be very
important
okay yeah I'm just so uh upset about the
whole Roe versus Wade thing I have a
daughter and I worry about her future
but sure you know I feel like
Washington's gonna be okay but it's you
know I just so freaked out about the
future understandable well listen let's
see what the races are looking like as
we approach November and then figure out
where you want to get involved you know
yeah that sounds like a good idea thank
you all right Cliff from Seattle thank
you very much we're going to listen to
this victory speech momentarily I want
to say thanks to Wookie Jack Cactus Matt
erroneous temps and my bag of mangoes
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 118 let's listen to this
trumpist lunatic Revel in his victory
you know follow the science
uh-oh
it's already bad
only a Democrat can get away with failed
policies of setting the stick in their
homes killing thousands and get away
with it and and they're darling of
course would be promoted to Admiral
Woman of the Year oh my God anyway
but uh we
they like to call people who stand on
the Constitution far right and extreme I
repudiate that that is crap
[Applause]
which the media stands for and advocates
for they've gone extreme they're the
ones that sent us the sick back in our
homes their policies Democrat policies
what and kill so many that's extreme
that's extreme forcing your kids a mask
up that's extreme forcing health care
workers to lose their job not to getting
a job
this guy is barely coherent down half of
the small business in our state and put
people out of their life
that's extreme
our view for Pennsylvania is one of Hope
and freedom that people come here and
walk as they see fit not as some
Governor or some media hack sees fit
that's right
we're going to restore the dream to
Pennsylvania a place where you want to
come and live we're going to be the most
prosperous state in the nation we're
going to open up our energy sector like
you've never seen it before our yep
this guy is actually creeping me out
Mission energy producer number one
that's going to bring jobs here life
here Prosperity here it's going to be a
Marvel to watch
you know Josh Shapiro is backed by dark
money by unions by corruption
they think they think hey Will He Go
anti-semitic on Josh Shapiro 20 and 30
million dollars around
but the people of Pennsylvania we're no
longer asleep and we do not consent
we saw in our own race here
one one guy had like 16 million dollars
right and it's like single digits I mean
you can't buy you cannot buy elections
anymore maybe that was true before
covides are wide open
I know as you travel the state here
we have a massive movement of people
from the width and length of
Pennsylvania who don't always agree with
us on all issues in fact many of them
used to be Democrats and recently
switched they could vote for us here and
this is fantastic
John this is going to be a race to get
involved in too I this we got to make
sure this guy loses we're out collecting
he's got to keep an eye on that phone
there sorry
as you're out there collecting a record
number for Republican government
hurricane a 29 000 signatures get me on
the ballot you converted fat it was
beautiful thank you for doing that
that that's when this that's when the
swamps are like uh oh maybe we should
not discount this I don't know a thing
about Josh Shapiro other than just from
his name I assume he's a Jewish guy uh
but I'm supporting Josh Shapiro I'm
gonna work Remy and I you know thanks
with together with you we had the
hardest working campaign in this primary
we're gonna have the hardest working
campaign in this general election
this guy's really an inspirational
speaker huh
[Applause]
anyone watch our bus tour last week
anyone paying attention saw that several
stops were in traditional Democrat
strongholds like Pittsburgh and Erie
Erie Erie downtown Erie we had 500
people come to us something's definitely
Eerie about this speech that's for sure
I mean it's fantastic this is infectious
here because we all love freedom
everyone wants to walk and live as free
men and women right
[Music]
let's just see out of curiosity I just
want to see
um
okay
can we see how many votes Shapiro got I
know he was unopposed but where can I
say I can't I was curious how many
people went and voted for him unopposed
just in comparison to all the people
that voted in the GOP Primary
but I I guess that that information is
not there
on day one I'll be happy to reinstate
any uh National Guard member or air
guard
is it a job for job requirements
and
on day one school transparency will be
ordered
okay
I mean there's so much here on day one
CRT is over
there it is many of you in the chat I
know were waiting for that Senator Doug
mastriano declaring Victory uh in his
Republican primary to be the next
governor candidate from the Republican
Party in the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania he'll be facing off against
the Kearney current attorney general
Democrat Josh Shapiro Josh Shapiro
currently has covid and is not going to
be coming out to speak uh he is at home
speaking this evening because of that uh
but let me bring in uh Dana and Abby
because what we saw there was wow what a
what a situation what a situation the
lead for Dave McCormick is now only
[Music]
1.2 percentage points this is very much
not good
very very much not good
um
voicemail
hey David I had a question do you think
that the turnout in the primary
on the Republican side and on the
Democratic side
tells you anything about the turnout in
the general or indicates at all which of
those two candidates would win I don't
know uh it's a historical question we
just have to look up whether it's
predictive
um and I don't I don't know the answer
but I'll research it let's speak to a
couple of other people how about Ashley
from I believe it's Colorado is that
right
Ashley from C it says CEO I can't is it
Colorado Ashley you're on the air
hmm
oops oh God
I
click disconnect right when I heard it I
apologize for that let's go to
Jeremiah's from is it Ashbury or
Ashville Maybe
Ashburn Virginia okay there you go
welcome
great uh and it's hiramis uh I'm from
Argentina as well oh no way okay
beautiful I love it yeah
anyway uh a vital question please
empanadas yes uh how did I know I have
to tell you right when you said you were
you you're from Argentina and you'd be
asking a vital question I knew it would
be about empanadas okay go ahead yeah
empanadasos well I am I'm off pork
currently
um so there's no ham and cheese for me
but I'm not familiar empanadas let me
let me see I don't know I don't actually
know what's in there triangle shaped
it's just honestly it's it's a bunch of
beef and onions I don't think I've ever
had that to be honest but that sounds
great
yeah yeah they're really good is that a
regional thing
that's a good question it might just be
a quarter a quart of a thing yeah yeah
I'm not certain on that one we're gonna
have to look into that yeah
second question are you watching the
Celtics game right now no I'm not get
what who's winning
Miami just started winning uh in the
middle of the third quarter Celtics were
beating them most of the time oh my God
Miami what a disaster what a disaster
I'll have to go check that out if I if
after the stream if it's still going on
gotcha yeah and third some may say this
is the most important question uh your
beard shaving what happened oh yeah
every once in a while I just start fresh
it's good it lets you see if there's any
ingrown hairs or any other things that
have to be dealt with true yeah gotcha
love the show David adios all right
thank you so much we'll see you that
what a beautiful phone call I like that
one that was a good one
um as we stand by let's get an update
here on the Mehmet numbers still a 1.2
percentage point lead for Dave McCormick
uh let's see what else we've got here
um anybody else that wants to say hello
what about Zach from Delaware Zach go
ahead
hey David how you doing today I'm doing
well
sorry
um so I was just curious um I live in
Delaware so Delaware is a state where if
you want to vote in a primary it's not
open you have to be registered to party
so yes as a progressive what I
understand where there's you as a member
of Independent Media wanting to stay
registered independent do you think it's
important for progressives to make sure
that they're able to push the Democratic
party more Progressive and register if
it's required in their states absolutely
absolutely everybody should advocate for
the policies that they want and
progressives are part of that 100
percent
all right thank you
all right thank you very much very uh
succinct question but I like it let's go
to Spencer from Pennsylvania Spencer
we're watching your state very closely
right now
Spencer from Pennsylvania you're on the
air
Spencer from Pennsylvania welcome
all right
let's go to Matt from Virginia Matt go
hey uh with your look on you know
current politics at least for the
Democrats being yes on the more negative
side what's your view just more in
generally in you know broadly speaking
the outlook for the United States and
you know the last next 10 years you know
is it you know generally positive or
generally negative
um at least because me for for me
personally I feel that the next 10 years
will be generally negative in terms of
you know how the United States operates
even internally and externally speaking
you know my tendency on these things is
to be a natural cautious optimist so my
default would be to say no I do think
that by many indicators we're going to
continue to see things improve but I
have to tell you
Roe v Wade being done away with if
indeed that's what happens that's a
major right-wing Victory and it puts in
doubt some of my natural cautious
optimism so I I don't know I'm not
feeling as optimistic as I normally
would
okay I mean so like I was thinking more
so like do you foresee the United States
you know losing its dominant superpower
status geopolitically or something to
that effect you know maybe it's the US
Dollars being the reserve currency I
think it's definitely plausible
that in a decade
um it may indeed be China that is sort
of the superpower and the U.S would be
secondary I I don't think that that's
crazy to think is a possibility a decade
out
okay I mean would you can would you
think that's
um maybe maybe not so much beneficial
for the United States but for the World
At Large maybe or China to be stronger
than the US it's not obvious to me that
China being the dominant superpower is
good for the world I'm not saying it's
not but it's not obvious to me that it
would be I'd have to be convinced of
that
okay I'm I'm glad you have more optimism
than I do at least all right very good
well thank you for the call Matt
okay very good uh let's see if we can
squeeze oh let me go back to Ashley from
Colombia or Columbus I'm sorry I heard
you and then hung up at the last second
there turns out it was a few seconds
behind on the Stream So I switched over
as fast as I could God I just want to
say I love the show thank you been
watching for a long time first time
caller thank you I was wondering what
your thoughts on so now that Roe v Wade
has I know what not officially but has
essentially been overturned has been
shown to be that they're gonna overturn
it right and with Republicans pretty
much in my opinion on winning on
suppressing votes in most of the country
yeah do you think we're gonna see a real
like scoping in on not I know they're
already attacking trans people like I've
been firsthand of that but do you think
that they're gonna go back to issues
like gay marriage inside of me and start
specific attacks against that again even
though now that most Republicans are in
favor of gay marriage I think it's I saw
something that was like 50 some it was
like real close listen I think they
absolutely are going to go after those
things every time I say it somebody will
write in saying David that's a slippery
slope or whatever they're telling us
that they're going to do it hey stand by
one second we have a key race alert just
hold on uh race alerts uh let's go now
to the Republican Senate primary in
Pennsylvania former hedge fund manager
Dave McCormick still in the lead okay so
the alert is they don't have a result in
Pennsylvania yeah listen they're telling
us that they want to go further Charlie
Kirk said it Greg Abbott said it I'm not
literally saying they're going to try to
end into racial marriage I think that
they realize that's probably not a good
idea but they absolutely are going to
try to go further there's no doubt about
it
all right thank you for your Insight on
that all right thank you so much thank
you appreciate it
um okay uh we are unlikely to have
Pennsylvania results anytime soon so
this is going to end my coverage for
today I've got to get up in the morning
and get tomorrow's show done okay so we
are going to wrap our coverage here
Madison cawthorne has been defeated and
that is a delightful bit of news I know
that there's a lot of not great news
coming out of tonight including that
mastroiani mastroni I forget exactly how
he spells his name
um has one that's not good but it is a
it is a pleasure that Madison cawthorne
has lost per Dave Wasserman I know that
CNN hasn't yet called it so I will be
back with everybody tomorrow to review
all of it I really appreciate everybody
that joined me it's been an incredible
evening we will be back next Tuesday
with more results and more Insanity
thank you to everybody who supported it
and we will see you very very soon check
out this video on our way out
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
s
[Music]
from elephants and bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged